this is a production of cornell
university
welcome everyone uh i'm excited to
introduce sophie and kamoon
as our sips plenary speaker today sophie
is a group leader at the sainsbury
laboratory and a professor of biology at
the university of east anglia
sofian is a world scientist in every
possible sense of the term
he was raised in tunisia he did his
undergraduate work in genetics at the
pierre and marie curie university in
paris
he did his phd work at the university of
california in davis
getting his phd in 1991
he was a research scientist in the
department of phytopathology at
wagenegan university in the netherlands
and then he pursued a faculty career
from assistant to full professor at the
wooster campus
of ohio state university between 1998
and 2007. in 2007 he became a group
leader
at the sainsbury laboratory uh
and between 2009 and 2014
he was head of the sainsbury laboratory
he was also president of the
international society for molecular
plant microbe interactions from
2012 to 2014. among his many many honors
in 2018 sofia received the linnaean
medal for outstanding contributions to
plant science
and he was elected a fellow of the royal
society
sofian's graduate work at davis used the
genetics approach to bacterial plant
pathogenesis
but his subsequent research has focused
on what is arguably
the supreme plant pathogen phytophthora
infestans
the omic agent of the late blight of
potato
which caused the irish potato famine in
the 1840s
and is a continuing threat to potato and
tomato crops to this day
sophie's investigation of this patho
system led him to become a pioneer
in pathogen genomics the activities and
evolution of pathogen effectors
which of course are key agents of
virulence and now the host immune
receptors that defensively detect
pathogen effectors and are key to the
protection
of the world's food supply
as you know we are now in the midst of a
pandemic
accordingly i would encourage you to
listen to sophie and seminar
with an awareness of a particular
feature of covet 19.
that is when we try to understand the
frighteningly diverse
and still unpredictable effects of sars
kobe 2
in individual humans we are repeatedly
led
to mysteries of the mammalian innate or
sorry the mammalian
immune system
whose variable and often mistuned
system responsiveness seems to be key
to both the devastating epidemiological
dynamics
and the symptoms of the disease
covid19 thus makes us more aware of the
systems
level challenge that all higher
organisms face
in managing their innumerable biotic
threats
sofian seminar is particularly timely
because he is leading the world in
understanding how plants
handle this universal systems level
challenge
his seminar title is beyond single genes
how receptor networks underpin plant
immunity
i should note that at the conclusion of
the seminar graduate student zoe de
brogle
will moderate the question period and
then there will be a remote lunch with
graduate students
so sophie and my old friend and
traveling companion
remotely welcome it is all yours
thank you so much adam that was a very
inspiring introduction thank you so much
and um i um
i actually reworked the talk this
morning and i wanted to give a new talk
uh and also uh in part because we've
done some work during the lockdown we've
been in lockdown for several months
my lab is is only uh partly back
into the wet lab at least part of it
so we decided to start some new projects
uh to provide really computational and i
decided to talk of them some of them are
still working progress as you see
uh but i thought it would be fun to to
uh to
work them in but uh the the message
really is
and it it totally um joins what what you
were saying alan is
that the immune system is very complex
and
part of the issue uh and probably part
of the issue of why we have also
problems with
covet 19 and sarskoff too is
that the immune system of course is a
result of evolution
and evolution is messy and so you end up
with these very complex
networks uh that can very easily go
wrong
somehow they tend to function well uh
despite everything
but they can also easily go wrong and i
think that's that's perhaps the
the the theme here uh is is really how
evolution has led um immunity and immune
receptors
to to function in a very complex manner
and took them through all kind of
trajectories
uh which some of them are perhaps
unexpected and probably not the sort of
things we were thinking about when these
immune receptors were first identified
back in the 90s
okay so um and and it's it's again it's
a pleasure to be here uh
i wish i could be uh physically in uh
in ithaca but uh it's an absolute
pleasure to to
to be here and again many old friends
including um
alan and a wonderful chip we had
together back in 2004 and
and gideon um very much supporting early
days of my career with the fight after
uh consortium genomics consortium uh a
huge pleasure many friends in it again i
really hope i can
i can visit okay so uh 2020 was
the um international is the
international year of penthouse i said
it was it's kind of
it's interesting because maybe it turned
out to be more the year of covet
and and there is a petition to try to
expand the international year of plant
health
2021. uh but uh indeed
pathogen caused a lot of destructive
disease this is an example here with
blast it's a
our own type of pandemic in plant
pathology
but when pathogens
break through then
they they can overcome
so i i lost my thought here but uh the
so even though uh pathogens can cause
very uh nasty and destructive diseases
uh there's one um universal feature in
plant pathology
is that most plants are resistant to
most pathogens
so if we were to make a matrix for
example
of a thousand plants and a thousand
pathogens
in most cases we will have resistance
and very few cases will have disease
and this is has been known for a long
time but i think what's becoming clear
over maybe the
last 20 years or so is that the reason
why most plants are resistant to most
pathogens is because they have
an effective immune system and they can
fight off
pretty much most of most plant pathogens
and there are now some immunocompromised
mutants
implants that are taking up
more pathogens and allowing more micro
uh colonization than a normal
wild type plant would so
um when pathogens break through uh we
have
this concept of effectors
and now we know that um pretty much all
pathogens
whether they're microbial pathogens or
the insect pathogens or
nematodes or even parasitic plants
they deliver effectors to various
various compartments in houseplant
and these effectors are
targeting a number of plant components
uh they either inhibit them co-opt
pathways or sometimes
uh essentially create a short circuit by
connecting uh
independent pathways in the host all to
their benefit
and they often suppress immunity but
they
can do more than just suppressability so
pathogens have evolved
these effectors to uh essentially better
plant processes
and enable a more hospitable host
environment
but plants haven't been sitting either
and one of these
remarkable concepts in our field
is that some effectors even though they
evolved
to favor the pathogens some effector can
trip the wire
and get detected by immune receptors
and plants carry a large number of
immune receptors some genomes have
hundreds of these this can be the cell
surface receptors of the pattern
recognition type
or they can be intracellular receptors
of the
nlr family previously known as mbs and
lr but now we prefer to use the term nlr
to
to be consistent with other systems such
as the
uh animal mammalian system so these
receptors can detect effectors and
uh often all it takes for the plant is
to have a single receptor that detects
one pathogen
for the plant to really win the battle
and and
stop the ingress of of the pathogen
so a few interesting uh points to uh to
mention here first
of all um the um immune receptors
turned out to be uh more often than not
the products of
uh genetically defined resistance genes
so our genes
have been known for over a century
uh they used routinely in plant breeding
uh they're very useful uh for research
too because
uh genetic diversity they tend to vary
between
germplasm with interim plants between
different accessions of the plant
species and
so they can be readily crossed using
classical
rarely identified using classical
genetics and some of that
pioneering work has been done at cornell
for example pto
gene was identified using classical
genetics by
uh crossing and comparing different
tomato accessions
so uh uh more often than not our genes
turn out
to code for immune receptors and um
and this is uh interesting because just
the feature i just told you about
which is that our genes tend to be
variable within germplasm and within
species
uh is uh actually part of a wider
message is that
uh this co-evolution that's going on
between plants and pathogens between
immune receptors and effectors
is very dynamic and is has driven a
massive
diversification of the effectors and the
plant immune receptors and um
i can argue that effectors and
immunoreceptors are actually the most
diverse protein family in the majority
of plant pathogens and plants
this is not always true but this is
generally
true in many cases when genomes of
many pathogens including the one worked
on
and and also plans are sequenced we
identify these
gene families are being the most complex
and most diverse
and this to some degree makes sense
because this interaction between
effectors evolving to favor the pathogen
but occasionally when that pathogen
lands on the plant that carries an
immune receptor that detects one of
these effectors
and activate immunity then we have uh
that effector becomes a liability so
this is inherently an unstable
evolutionary situation
that results in in essentially an
oscillating
selection forces which result in this
diversification more often perhaps that
not
to enable some form of bad hedging where
um
large families of effectors are doing
similar jobs and so enable the pathogen
to actually
lose one of them or have one or few of
them being detected by the plant but
still be able to to do the business of
of uh suppressing immunity causing
disease and all that
so the uh the the the first observation
here which is really what came out of
genomic studies more than anything is
that these families of effectors and
and immune receptors are almost mirror
image of themselves in in being very
complex and also
uh forming uh complex gene clusters and
diversifying at
really sometimes astonishing rates uh in
the very
various pathogen implant genomes
okay so what i would talk about today is
the nlr
type of immune receptors so a bit of an
introduction to these
these are intracellular immune receptors
they're intracellular sensors of
invading pathogens
so they detect the factors that are
delivered inside the plant cell
and they are also found in mammalian
systems
humans have them uh also found in fungi
more recently even there are
descriptions of the melar type
proteins in bacteria although their
function hasn't been yet
fully resolved uh what's interesting is
that
implants uh just like in other systems
these are modular uh
proteins that carry an npr domain so
this is a nucleotide binding domain
the central domain which binds atp
and but that domain is generally flanked
by two other domains the c
terminal one is which repeats so this is
a common domain implant nlr-type
proteins but
the internal domain tends to be more
variable so it can be either of the coil
coil type and
some subtypes or the the tier type
domain and i want to introduce also the
experimental system
i suppose many of you are familiar with
nicotiana bantamiana's but
it has been so important in research on
nlr's that it's really worth to mention
so benthy allows transient gene
expression
and it's really perfect for studies of
effector and lr interactions because you
can bring in the two components in the
system and essentially recreate
uh the interaction in uh in
microsoft only when you have
the immune receptor with its matching
effector uh we get the cell death
response the hypersensitive cell death
response which is
a hallmark or the readout we use really
for uh for the activation of nlr so
that's
uh part of the immune response and
that's
makes it uh really experimentally a very
robust and very accessible system where
we can
easily study these interactions using
nicosia benzema and only when you have
the two partners you get the immune
response
and this system have proven to be really
useful you can even bring monocot genes
so some rice
genes barrier genes can be expressed in
nicosiana benzema some of the nlrs and
if you provide them with
the proper effector or even if you make
autoimmune mutants
of those receptors you can visualize the
hypersensitive nicotine
i should also mention as shown on the
right side that
um the nicosiana benzemiana can also be
used for pathogen infections and we can
also see the hypersensitive cell death
so on the right side
you can see um an hr to phytophthora
infestance
so this few uh spores were uh placed on
that leaf and this particular nicotine
benzamiana is a
transgenic plant expressing an arginine
rpi
b2 against fight after infestance and
you can see the effect here only on the
on the on the race that is carrying the
proper effector and not on the uh not
with the
different rays of the pathogen so that's
our experimental system and you see a
few of those leaves uh
in in the talk so i wanted to um to
introduce that
uh i should also mention that the nlrs
were first
cloned in the early 90s and since then
uh quite a number of them uh in fact
that the last count 415
uh were experimentally validated and uh
this is one of our lockdown exercises so
yorgos corellis in my lab he
built this database called ref plant nlr
and this is the database of
all experimentally validated
it's not surprisingly you can see that
arabidopsis is quite dominant
but you can also see that quite a number
of nlrs have been validated in
solanum potato tomato pepper
and also in a number of monocots
notably in rice
what's already evident also from this
slide and this is
something that maybe will come up a
little bit later is you can see that
these different classes of nlrs
where they tend to vary depending on the
different plant taxes so arabidopsis
is quite atypical actually in carrying a
large number of tnlars
relative to the ccnlr type uh and that's
different situation from monocots for
example which don't have tier and allows
at all
and certainly uh also different from the
subanesi which tend to have more uh
ccnlrs
than uh tnlr's and this is again an
illustration of the
uh diversity and the complexity of of
these mlrs across
plant plan incidentally the database we
we just posted it in by archive a few a
few weeks ago
um uh we we we're still uh
building uh building up the paper but uh
one of the
advantage of it is that it does
highlight uh the lack of knowledge
there's so many uh
plant uh orders that haven't been
actually studied uh in terms of the nlr
biology
starting first with the non-flowering
plants
so only uh only uh nlars from flowering
plants have been
validated so it's actually useful also
as a guide
uh those of you who are interested in
plant diversity then you can also
identify which
uh which orders of plant
families haven't been studied in terms
of in allowed biology and i think
there's a lot of surprises there just by
looking at the genome it's evident that
there's some really interesting
diversification across different
plant families okay so the other uh
part of the introduction really is is
highlighting this uh
new dogma really we have in the field
which is very recent started about a
year ago
uh that activated nlrs oligomerized into
this structure we call resistosomes
and this is really beautiful work uh
pioneered first by uh gigi chai and
jamin zhu in beijing
uh with the za1 protein which is a
ccnlr-type protein
and then more recently by uh raul martin
working with eva nogales and brian
staskovitz working with the tier and
allah in this case with rock one
and both of these nlrs once they're
activated once they're triggered by
a pathogen effector they bind atp
switch off to binding atp and then they
oligomerize into these resistosome
we like structures which are either a
phantom
in the case of zar1 or in the case of
rock one the
it's a tetramer and this oligomerization
process
is absolutely essential for the
activation of these
molecular machine if you like and for
the capacity to trigger the
hypersensitive
cell i'll be talking about ccnlr so i
want to
uh spend a little more time on zr1 and
house r1 undergoes
uh this conformational switch
to uh form the resistor zone
so in its inactive state as you can see
on the left side
r1 is actually folded into
a quite a stable state
once it's switched on by the pathogen
effector in this case through the
activation of the kinase of the
receptor-like cytoplasmic kinase type
the rnck
it switches on to binding atp and then
forms the oligomer
and then there is a very dramatic
a fault switch that conformational
switch that happens at the end term is
very in terminus of of the r1 i don't
know if you can see my
my cursor but um it's
uh it's right on the bottom of the
intermediate state there and what
happens there is that alpha helix which
is normally folded within the cc domain
now uh is protruding from the helix and
if you uh go all the way back to the
right side of the panel
then uh the five alpha helices form a
funnel-like shape
which is thought to insert into the
membrane into the plasma membrane
and forming a pore and directly causing
the toxic response that is
leading to the cell death this part has
a question mark as you can see
because there's a number of details that
haven't been um determined yet but there
is a parallel in some of the animal
systems some of the mammalian systems
not only with the apoptosion
where a similar process also involves
perturbation of
the the cell membrane causing directly
toxicity in the same way as poor forming
toxins would
cause cell death and toxicity
but what i want to highlight here really
is that n terminus because i would be
talking about that again
and that that conformational switch
let's call it the death switch is
absolutely critical for the activation
of the r1 and
is directly linked to the capacity of
the r1 to cause
the cell death response
okay so um i'm going to start with the
end here so i
i decided that what i will do first is i
will tell you uh
what the end of the story is
and i will start with the model and
essentially what really our research has
led
us to discover and then after that i'll
go through some of the details and some
of the um
the results but i thought it would be
useful to start with the
um essentially the the model
we developed over these last years in
terms of our understanding of how
nlr proteins function and how they have
evolved
uh into their current uh expanded
and diverse state so the uh
main asp main component of this model is
that throughout evolution we started
with ancestral nlrs that are
multifunctional so they can do both jobs
which are really the two primary
businesses of
of mlrs one is sensing pathogens
sensing pathogen effectors and the
second one is
activating the immune response and so
the idea is that the ancestral receptors
are multifunctional they can detect
pathogens sometimes directly sometimes
indirectly
through intermediate protein
and and but at the same time the same
protein the same
exact biochemical unit can also
trigger the immune response and our
model is that throughout evolution
uh this multifunctional effect receptors
have
specialized into two types of
receptors some will call sensors and the
other ones helpers and the sensors being
essentially receptors that have now
specialized into detecting the pathogen
some of the sensor incidentally have
acquired new domains
which are often evolved from targets
host targets of the effectors and so
they
by acquiring these domains into the
canonical mlr architecture they're using
these domains as baits essentially
for the for the effector
but the interesting bit here is that
those sensors are not able to
elicit trigger the immune response on
their own they depend on helper nlrs
which are genetically downstream and and
cause
the uh cell death response
hypersensitive death
and immune response now this is the
model that we have and so the idea here
is we start with
multifunctional singleton ancestors that
diversified into pairs and there's a
number of my colleagues
work on nlr pairs but we believe that
these pairs also have evolved into the
networks as
describe the one we discovered but i
think there's also more networks out
there in the nlr world
this said i should also mention that not
all the nlrs
have evolved in this way so we also
think that there is a subset of mlrs
there's not many of those perhaps not as
many as
as the networked or paired and allows
but some of these nlrs have remained
as multifunctional units throughout
evolution
and what i mean by that that they can
still carry the sensor and helper
activity
in one single nlr protein
in this case though as the cartoon here
illustrates the diversification has not
occurred in the nlr protein
but often in the gardee or the decoy and
i'll get back to this towards the end of
the talk but it's important to also
realize that in addition to this paired
and
networked nlr's some of these have
remained uh
as multifunctional receptors throughout
their air pollution
so that's essentially my uh my take home
message so i'll
start with that i think it will make
things more clear and then i'll i'll
i'll
i'll get to the the details of of the uh
of the research we've done so the
question we had
over the last years in my lab is
really an evo and pmi question so an
evolutionary molecular plant microbe
interactions
question and approach so in the same way
that our colleagues work on development
have evolved i think we should also have
an evo and pmi field in our
research field which is really the
consequence of
essentially the two independent fields
one being genomics which
a lot of genomics is actually
phylogenomics
and and this coupled with uh essentially
uh the advances we make in our
mechanistic understanding of how these
different proteins function
and how they operate and so by combining
these two fields
we can start asking questions about
that directly link evolutionary features
with uh mechanistic research now that's
what really evo mpmi is about it's about
linking
molecular mechanisms with evolution look
at them from an evolutionary angle
so the question we have here is if
indeed
nlrs have evolved from multifunctional
effectors to pair the networked proteins
what are the molecular consequences of
these evolutionary
transitions and how does that help us
understand how this proteins function
and also understand also how they have
diversified into the
um into the complex
and alarms we see today in various plant
genomes
and this is the network we discovered
and we study again i'm
trying to start really with the models
at the end i think it's a lot easier
than
keeping that at the end of the talk so
this is the network we discovered we
call it the nrc network it's a network
that's found in asterisk species it has
particularly diversified in the solar
nation
and as you can see in this cartoon
there's a lot of
famous argentines here so i'll start
with
prf which recognizes avr pto and avr
ptob
through the pto kinase sorry the pityro
kinase and not in this cartoon but there
are various
in many cases there are intermediates
between the effector and the nlr
uh i know and and various others i also
would mention rx because that's also
very well studied
protein that causes resistance to uh
potato virus
x and and there's a number of others
here
shown in this network and what we
discovered essentially is that a lot of
these are genes that were cloned
dating back to the 90s really through
primarily through classical genetic
approach because they were tended to be
diverse within germplasm these
are genes turn out to be sensor nlrs
that are dependent on other nlrs
downstream of them which are helper nlrs
and these nlrs are what
members of the nrc family
so uh at this moment we know quite a few
of them
uh we're up to an rc9 actually but i'm
for simplicity i'm only showing you the
three major ones in rc two three
and four how we found this network
is really interesting so i'm gonna take
you through that that story so it's a
little bit of a parenthesis here but i
think it's worth it because especially
for the early career scientists there i
think it's it's an interesting
thing to reflect on uh how we we ended
up actually discovering this
as you can see one of the features of
this network is redundancy so if you
take for example prf pto
excuse me prfp2 it's
uh it's using an rc2 and an rc3
so you really need to eliminate both an
rc2 and rc3 to lose the prf
pto type resistance if you look at rx
rx uses an rc2 an rc3 and an rc4 so it
has actually three
redundant downstream nlrs that it can
function with
so as you can imagine this is difficult
to discover genetically through
classical
genetic screens and so on and this could
explain why it took a while for
this network to be to be discovered
so how did we find it well we found it
because uh as
alan uh mentioned in his introduction um
my career really uh took off with the
fight after infestance genome
and by sequencing the genome we were
able to
do things totally differently new way of
doing business which incidentally is a
sentence i picked up from alan colmer
when we were traveling back in 2004 in
korea and i
really uh he mentioned that he said
that's what genomics
allows you to do and and i i kept using
it ever since
so it was very inspiring um catchphrase
i thought
uh and and uh the the point here what is
it
doing our new new way of doing business
really is that
we now have four referred to our
genes for example of pathogen genes and
we can predict the genes that look like
effectors
and i don't need to get into details
here but there's various ways of doing
that
including the fact that they tend to be
secreted proteins therefore carry signal
peptides and also the fact that they can
have certain motifs that allows you to
identify them among the
secretom of the
the pathogen so now you have a
essentially a collection a list of genes
that you can
uh clone and make libraries of
you can now use the bentamiana system to
express them
um using various different expression
systems
in the early days we use pvx potato
virus x as a vector to deliver these
effectors and if you co-express your
effector collection with an
arginine with an nlr such as rpi build
v2
in some cases some of these effectors
will cause
and rpi will be too dependent cell death
and that becomes your uh candidate
effector avr effector that's detected by
this particular
nlr so this is the kind of work we did
and uh this led to the discovery of
various uh avr effectors that activate
certain immune receptors including the
one
avr blb2 so this called here in this old
slide rd39940
this turned out to be avr build b2 which
activate the
nlr rpi b2 uh
potato nlr that functions against fat
off train systems
so uh back to uh 2012 when shihan wu
joined my lab to start a phd we were uh
at that stage we were really intrigued
by rpi build v2 and avrb2 and
we um decided that
shahan would work on understanding this
interaction a little better
in particular he the question he had
really initially was how does rpi build
b2 detect
avr baby too sadly i can
tell you today that we still don't know
how rpi built v2 detects avrb2 but
as often in science the the research
led us to quite some uh surprising
directions i should mention here that
this is
from a tweet by shihan from just a
couple of days ago where he just
launched his lab at
ipmb in academia cynica in taiwan where
he's located now
so um so best wishes to him it's always
very exciting to
to start a new love and he's he's really
a
great very rigorous and uh
very talented scientist
so what happened is shihan was
interested in rpi bv2 so you can see it
here on the top right again if you don't
see my cursor is on the top right second
one from the right
so that's rpi bb2 it detects avr b2 from
fight after infestance
but as you can see unlike most of the
other nlrs in this network
it's only uh using an rc4 so it's only
dependent on an rc4 downstream so
there's no genetic redundancy here
and that was our track of like luck
really um
in that we could identify an rc4 as a
downstream component
because there was no redundancy so that
was really uh fortunate for us
and um and then uh using a phylogenomic
approach that was essentially the
the thread in the in the sweater we kept
pulling and that
resulted in discovering the the full
network
and uh these days with uh crispr we can
actually
make lines that are imitated in multiple
in our season and confirmed the various
phenotypes that we generated using virus
induced in silencing
in the early days so the key feature of
this network perhaps the most important
feature really and the most important
discovery of sheehan during his phd was
that the
network is phylogenetically structured
this is also what allowed us to really
hypothesize that other nrcs are involved
so as you can see here all the analyses
all the helpers all the downstream
components are in this one clade and the
sister clayton
the one that's massively expanded is the
one that
includes all the uh nrc dependent
sensors we identify
so it does look like this is a network
that has evolved from
a pair of genes and presumably even
before that a single gene
that over evolutionary time has expanded
into this complex
uh network and that's really an
important feature of this nrc network
which really gives us the power to
predict uh connections between different
nrcs and their sensors and i would
mention also that the
expansion has occurred before solanaceae
split from other asteroids so we have
species like
lettuce for example like olive tree
and others that have an expanded nrc
network
but also uh the solanaceae have an
expanded
nrc network so we trace back the
expansion of the network to about 100
million years ago
i should also uh mention that we now
have sub networks we identify additional
nrcs so for example nrc6
this is a sub network which is actually
part of a gene cluster
and nrc6 is root specific it's not
expressed in leaves
and it's functioning with a nematode
resistance gene known as hero
in tomato so uh there are sub networks
that evolved also
uh from that uh that pair of nlrs that i
mentioned and also
uh nrc0 is another cluster which is
unusually conserved across multiple
species and
we think that this is the ancestor
actually nrc
uh in in this particular phylogenetic
network
so uh we if we step
beyond the hundred million years and we
look at some uh
species that carry nrcs but i don't have
the
expanded number of analyses and we can
see for example that in the carrier
filler list we have a limited number of
of nls from this phylogenetic clade in
fact in in sugar beet there's only three
of them
one is an rc type and the other two are
sensor like
so they both cluster in the different
clades of the nrc network
uh but that's it that's all we found in
that entire genome
so essentially this is probably what we
think is the ancestor
configuration that there was just a pair
of genes
uh some other species we find only one
nrc type
so we think that from that single or
pair of genes over
a hundred million years we had this
expansion so if you look at the tomato
genome for example then
you have nrcs and their sensors are
essentially spread throughout the genome
in multiple clusters
with various levels of complexity and
also
paired nrcs and sensors are not
necessarily linked so this is a
genetically unlinked network which is
i think a really interesting feature of
this network
okay so the model here is really we
started with a singleton nlr that was
carried both activity and throughout
evolution it these
genes have specialized into sensors and
helpers
and then they uh diversified into this
complex network so now back to that
question what happened at the molecular
level as these
nlr specialized into sensors and helpers
what happened to their various
activities
and this is a project that uh also
started
uh a bit as an accident and actually
started as part of a frustration because
we knew that the nrcs were helpers and
we
expected them to carry um essentially
the capacity to induce cell death on
their own and that's actually true
because if we make an autoactive nrc and
we express it in the casino benzamiana
it does cause cell death it's not
dependent on
other sensors as far as we can tell but
what's really interesting here uh what
was really frustrating to us is that if
we express the internal domain the cc
domain on its own
it actually failed to cause cell death
and that was a bit nagging me
because we expect helpers to really have
auto active
cc domains and that wasn't the case here
so when aki
adachi joined the lab we decided to do
something we decided to do a transposon
mutant screen where we create
essentially truncations of our nrc
with the hope of finding mutant that
will cause the cell death
a truncation that will actually be auto
active and
anaki took on that challenge it was a
fun uh
method development uh project too
because
you you do in vitro transposon
metagenesis here to create essentially a
truncation
library uh express them in benzamiana
and
the project more or less failed actually
except for this one single
construct this truncation of only 29
amino acids
and the first 29 amino acids of nrc4
were sufficient to coarseness everything
has failed it was it was a bit of a
surprising result we really didn't know
what to make of it at the time we
um we kind of shelved it a little bit uh
for
uh maybe a year uh as we were posted
we knew it was a robust result but
we just didn't know how to interpret it
and then uh we also showed that this
truncation uh could cause cell death
independently of the full length nrc4 so
it wasn't
really uh requiring the full it wasn't
like associating with the full length
protein and
and causing um the cell death to some
sort of
uh oligomeric state with uh with the
full-length protein so it was really
able to cause cell death on its own
so now fast forward to the zar1 work and
so when we saw the zawan
uh structure uh we uh immediately went
aha this is it this is this explains our
result because
essentially what the one model shows is
that n terminus that alpha helix
which is about 23 amino acids actually
of the first 23 amino acids of the r1 so
very close to the
n-terminus we had that's the part that
is actually doing the business of
causing the cell death and
perturbing the membrane through poor
insertion
and with when we compare the zar1 and
terminus to the nrc and terminus
uh it was strikingly similar so these
two proteins even though one is from
arabidopsis and the other one
is from tamiana or tomato
we had very similar in termina in fact
in that first alpha helix about half the
residues were identical
so that was a really exciting result and
we um decided to
um explore that further so we first
stepped back and and
started asking whether the n-terminus of
these
proteins is financially the cc domain
uh whether they were related to each
other so um
as a bit of a technical point here when
you do phylogenies of
nlrs you have to use the mbr domain
because that's the only domain that is
conserved across all the nlrs from
all plant species uh you can't really do
that with the cc domain because they
tend to be quite diverse and quite
diversions so you can't really build the
phylogenetic tree with the cc domains
your alignments are really poor
so the way to approach a problem problem
like that is to first group this and
termini
into families or tribes based on
sequence similarities
so this is what we did we took a bunch
of plant species
dicots monocots uh grouped them uh
extracted there and germini and then did
this
tribe big exercise to group the end
terminal in different
sequence similar families if you like or
protein families
and then what you could see here is that
tribe two which is the second largest
in in this exercise uh includes
the nrcs but also includes r1 and few
other nlrs that are also well studied
so it's interesting that these
n-terminus
of z1 is actually related to the
n-termini
of these nrcs then we did
a motif search on each of the tribes and
if we do that motif search for using the
program
meme using tribe two then uh one of the
motives that is
uh revealed by meme is the exact n
terminus
so this is the region that corresponds
to that alpha helix observe one that
flips out
and forms the funnel-like structure so
we call this
motif the mother motif for this mada
starting residues and this motif was
present in about
70 percent of all tribe 2 mlrs
and also in about 20 percent
of all the ccna and as you can see here
this motif really uh matches very nicely
with that alpha helix
uh in in the zawan structure if we look
at
which nlrs carry the mother motif one of
the interesting and perhaps surprising
thing
is that this 20 percent is one fifth of
the ccnlrs
that carried the motif actually spread
throughout
the phylogenetic tree of the analyse
again remember this tree is based on the
nbr the conserved domain
and if you ask the question which of
these nlrs carry the mother motif
then you see even pic2 is a rice protein
for example
zr1 is an arabidopsis protein rpp13 is
arbitopsis
but then rpi vnt1 r2 and dnrcs are from
solanaceae from solanum species so we
have a diversity of plants that have
actually
this madam motif but
really the majority of the ccnlrs don't
carry this notice
we did some functional work and i don't
spend too much time on this this is
published and
and and i um i really uh want to skip
this because
uh i just realized actually i really
went fast
uh but the point here really is that the
one and the nrcs have interchangeable uh
sequences so we can confirm that indeed
this is a functional sequence
this is the interesting bit so the nrc
dependent
sensors on the other hand they lack this
sequence and they come in all kinds of
tribes as you can see here shown in blue
these uh these sensors the ones that are
dependent on the nrcs
are actually very diversion from the
nrcs in their
cc domain and the end terminal
know and if we map this into the nrc
network
phylogeny you can see that the great
majority of the nrcs carry the mother
motif shown here in red
but none of the sensors including prf
rx and so on none of these have the
mother motif in fact some of these
sensors like prf for example they carry
an
n terminal integration before the
predicted cc domain fact prf has even
two cc domains
and and so that would really preclude
these proteins functioning
through as r1 type resistosm because
their n terminal essentially are not
free they're there
there's several hundred amino acids
before that
uh cc domain so uh essentially what we
think has happened here it's use it or
lose it these sensor nlrs have
specialized to become
sensors to detecting pathogens they're
not carrying the business of causing the
cell death
through the n-terminus of the protein so
their
uh madam motif there and termina have
become non-functional over evolutionary
time they have degenerated because this
protein have specialized
so if you go back to this model then
essentially what we see here
is that the sensors
they have now degenerated features they
lost the capacity to trigger cell death
on their own they don't have that mother
motif
they have even acquired internal domain
integration so they have diverse from
that canonical three domain
architecture but on the other hand the
helpers
they have retained that conserved and
terminated they have retained the
position of the mother motif at the end
terminus
through a long evolutionary time because
we do find this mother sequence in some
monocle templars for example
but not in uh in sensory analysis
okay so uh i'm gonna skip the
conclusions here because i really want
to tell you about very briefly here
about the singletons
and what i described now to you is uh
is a complex network where we have
specialization into sensors and helpers
throughout evolutionary time
but some nlrs are not like that so many
laws have been
functional singletons over long
evolutionary time and the classical
example here is r1 in fact that's the
most conserved nlr we can identify in
in uh in flowering plants through our
analysis
so we uh had this uh computational
program during the lockdown where we
wanted to explore uh
zarwan phylogeny and molecular evolution
and uh remarkably is i want
now to have many orthologs in
many plant species so we found in total
120 orthodox
so this glade here in red has 120 zar
ones
and they belong to 88 different plant
species
they trace back all the way to magnolias
and monocots so we have taro is a
monocot species that has a zarwan
we have also stout camphor and also
aquilegia which is an early dicot also
carries our one orthodox
so uh we uh and and the phylogeny of
zarwan essentially traces back the
species phylogeny so it's a classic
ortholog
core ortholog gene really across all
these different
flowering plant species so we date back
the r1
to anywhere from 150 to 220 million
years
uh which is really remarkable for an
enlarging they're not supposed to be
evolving like that they're supposed to
go through western death evolution
but that one is really atypical isn't an
exception so it is a
jurassic and life you like so when when
dinosaurs were roaming the earth there
was
presumably plants with with the tsar one
uh protein there
so the key feature here of this work is
really that the
um throughout this long evolutionary
time these are one ortholog retained the
key feature of the r1 so they retain the
madam motif
they remain retained the oligomerization
interface
and they also remain the kinase binding
interface so the rck binding interface
in the lr which determines the
specificity of what they interact with
with that has been retained and the
key residues in those interfaces are
pretty much invariant
so for a period of over 150 million
years we hypothesize that that one has
been
guarding essentially an rck for all this
time and the diversification has not
happened at the level of the nlr but
happened at the level of
of the kinases which we know from our
work from many colleagues
has indeed have indeed diversified
and co-evolved with various tsar ones
interestingly this analysis revealed and
conserved feature in the underside of
the resistors arm
so you can see this red ring here um on
the underside of these r1 orthologs with
a really nice conserved motif
we don't know what this means we
actually ordered the mutants we're uh
waiting for for those mutants to come
and i should also briefly mention that
there is a subclade of tsar one we call
it zhao one sub is shown here in blue
it's actually quite diverse it diverged
it
evolved in the dicots fairly early in
the dicot evolution
but i like zarwan and likes r1 this
clade has diversified and diverged quite
a lot so we don't find the mother motif
we don't find the oligomerization
interface
and the kinase interface has also
diversified
so we do think that this particular
subglade may have become
a sensor subplate perhaps working with
that one perhaps working with other nlrs
but this illustrates again the dynamic
features of the evolution of these mlr
so za1 is a
conserved atypically ancient nlr
but it did rig rise throughout evolution
to this blue glacier on here uh in in
various
dicot lineages and and that blue clade
presumably from a single duplication
event of an ancestors r1
has diversified somehow probably into
sensor and a large because it doesn't
carry a functional n-terminus
so uh it it
it just shows again how even this
ancient
atypical nlrs can still spawn
new nlrs with divergent features
so this has been a fun lockdown project
that we're uh now
it was a distraction for us at the time
but now we thought it's cool
enough that we're actually following
some functional research
so the take-home message really here is
that uh we should really
go beyond the uniform view of mlr
structure and function
we really should uh look at these nlrs
uh
first of all uh as more than a single
gene of single protein unit uh some of
them do function like that but
even those that are uh functioning as
single units like the r1
they still are have core receptors in
the in the sense
in the nature of these kinases which
have diversified
so uh essentially these
nlrs are pretty much always forming
these
complex networks and we think that this
network
feature of the immune system of the
receptors
is a very important feature uh which
allows them to diversify and allows them
also to be
to have a more robust immune response so
for instance
the sensors are now free to acquire new
domain
acquire new specificity diversion the
sequence without
being constrained by the capacity to
maintain the
uh ability to trigger the cell death so
for example they can acquire and
terminal integrations
whereas if they were helpers they
wouldn't be able to do that so having uh
essentially a network of receptors
uh makes the system a lot more evolvable
and probably a lot more robust
so i'll end there and
i want to thank the folks so i talked
about
jihan and aki uh but all the folks here
in particular more recently we have lida
and abbas
mauricio and toshi all of these really
contributed quite a lot to the nrc
project and more recently to the zarwan
evolution project
colleagues and collaborators um toga
boscort at imperial college mark
benfield that john lennis
and rio terauchi at
kyoto university and uh all the members
of my lab and also my colleagues at the
same relapse so thank you
uh so much and i hope this time for
questions
hi thanks so much sophia for the
excellent seminar um so
we have a few minutes for questions
and we can try to do hand raising or
you can type in the chat um and
i see that's a applause okay
so we have a question um first from jeff
doyle he asked does the phylogeny
correctly depict evolutionary
relationships in the nrcr gene family
our genes are known to be recomogenic so
perhaps a network approach would be more
suitable
yes so that's really interesting
uh point and in fact one of the
one of the projects we have now is
actually trying to predict
connections between nlrs so one of the
projects we have
is mining plant genomes for nlrs
and looking for clusters
somebody has a their phone but uh anyway
so looking for clusters of nlrs that
carry
both mother and non-mother uh nlrs
in that same cluster and and then having
the high poisons that
the mothers are forming the helpers and
the non-mother the
senses so this is um this is something
indeed we are really interested in
this has also implications for plant
breeding um
because um in some cases if the helper
happens to be diverse in your germplasm
you need to move two genes not just a
single gene to
to introduce resistance and
after we discovered the network we
actually established couple of
collaborations with industry uh just to
do
that because it's well known in plant
breeding that very often you have
resistance in one germplasm but if you
move it to a different
background um in an elite variety for
example
uh the resistance is either uh weaker
or sometimes even it's lost
so yeah that's a really good good
question
great and then we have a question from
adam bogdanov
um he says that it appears the sensor
helper divergence happened more than
once
um any sensor helper pairs that aren't
from the same ancient pair
um convergently involved dependencies
also please tell us about the gfp
nrc for localization in your slide
yeah so um okay so
uh the first question is that yes there
are
there are definitely pairs that are
stuck in that configuration
over evolutionary time so in rice for
example there are examples of that
the pia rga4 iga5 is an example
the one i mentioned in our system is an
rc0 so somehow the nrc0
is linked so that's an nrc that's
nnrc that is in the phylogeny appears to
be ancestral it's linked to nrc 0
dependent sensors
and that's conserved anywhere from
cotton coffee to tomato for example
so that's really um not cotton sorry
carrot carrot coffee and tomato
and and so that's quite quite surprising
case
so i'm not so sure about what the reason
is it could be that
they have specialized and are now
expressed by for example in specific
tissue and are
maybe dedicated to given pathogen or it
could be that the way they
mechanistically function
they cannot be separated so for example
if you have a negative regulator
then you really become a single genetic
unit and you can't separate that
otherwise there would be
a cost for the plant so i think that's a
really interesting question i think um
that's something we're very much aware
of and we're really looking into that
and trying to uh dig out cases where
um you have uh pairs that are
retained as pairs and and when they
duplicate they duplicate
as pairs actually so uh there are cases
like that
uh the second question is the gfp and
rc4 localization is
partly to the membrane uh there's just
too much gfp around so it's
um it's kind of hard to really uh say
but
it does the localization does overlap
with the plasma membrane
i should however mention that my
colleague toga boscort at imperial
college
does send biology of the nrcs
and they localize an rc4 to the
hostorial interface
so we do think that the nrc4 actually is
not functioning at the plasma membrane
but function at the level of the
extra-historian membrane
some of you may have heard talks by toga
or his students
on that topic they haven't yet published
the work but um
so we don't think that it's necessarily
the plasma membrane that's a target
could be other endomembrane compartments
great and then we have another question
uh from sharon tsuwanki
if the nlr system is converts to nrcs
and ultimately to pcd master regulators
then why pathogens are not directly
targeting the nrch and downstream
pathways
wow that's the question that's the slide
i removed
we have a project that we started very
early on uh we hypothesized early on
that
um there would be effectors that
suppress the nrc network and will target
the helpers
essentially it's like back one right for
the prr so if you're back one then
uh you're gonna be magnet for pathogen
effectors
so we hypothesize that the nrc helpers
are going to be
targets for solar nature's pathogens
and we screened actually um effectors
for that we have two candidates that we
followed up one is
from uh cyst nematode potato cyst
nematode
and the other ones from phytophthora
infestance interestingly enough
they are act at different levels the
systematic defector binds directly to um
to the nb domain of the nrcs
uh the phytophtha one uh acts through a
target
so it's there's that's indirect
suppression
but that's a great question indeed
that's a prediction you would make when
you have networks like that
and that could explain also why there
are multiple nrcs that have evolved
perhaps they
duplicated to evade pathogen suppression
that's one of the things that makes the
system more robust so if you have
multiple nrcs
working redundantly then it's harder for
pathogen to suppress all of them
great so if there are any more questions
please put them in the chat
um and i'd like to remind the graduate
students and postdocs
that after the starting around 1 50 i'll
open the alternate zoom room
and we'll have our lunch discussion
so i don't see any more questions
yet but if you have any more
you can send them to sophie and sophie
and you can take a break for a few
minutes and then join us in the
other zoom room when you're ready okay i
will and if anyone has any questions
please
get in touch directly or through twitter
or um
any other means happy to answer any
questions great
thank you so much thank you thank you
again and thank you everyone thanks alan
thanks
zoe thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu